Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! Thank you everybody
that submitted questions on my Game of Thrones
video yesterday. Everyone completely upset
about what happened in the episode actually
just careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
so we can start talking about it.
In case you guys didn't see Dan and Dave said
that George RR Martin explained to them what
was going to happen to Shireen eventually.
So that's why she ended up getting put to
the torch so even though it hasn't happened
in the books yet he implied that it would
be happening or it would have happened had
events gone down that way. Just to clarify, George
RR Martin said that because of the changes
the show has made, people will be dying on
the show that did not die in the books so
what he's done with Dan and Dave is help them
with the character arcs. So given the circumstances
that Stannis is faced with, this is the decision
that George RR Martin felt he would've made--
the gamble he would've made. It's a really
big gamble. He is betting that Melisandre is
right. Even though Shireen isn't dead in the
books right now she probably would've ended
up that way. It just might end up happening up at
the wall. That's what the implication is. Okay, so on to questions. Brian Gieson: do you think what happened to
Shireen in the show will happen in the books as well? Based on what George RR Martin said,
Yes, it will happen. Probably in a slightly different way though and for slightly different reasons.
In the books, Stannis left Shireen at
the wall whenever he marched onto Winterfell.
So if she's going to be sacrificed, it's not going to be until stannis gets back. And there are a lot
of spoiler theories as to why Melisandre might
need more king's blood up at the wall. We can
talk about that after the finale though so just put a bookmark in that. Next question, Black Fire
asks: So now that Stannis has burned his daughter and drank the last of Mel's lord of light
punch, how will Davos react once he returns? Will this be the final straw that causes him to
abandon Stannis? I don't know about
abandon him, but he is definitely going to
be questioning his faith. It's a nice balance
with what's going on with Tyrion and Daenerys
right now. Whenever Daenerys took off on Drogon, that was a moment of pure belief for Tyrion.
He is no longer a doubter. He totally
drinks the dragon kool-aid. Davos is probably
going to have the opposite reaction when he learns
about Shireen. And there's no telling how long
it's going to be before he finds out. He left to go to the wall before Stannis visited Shireen
so he has absolutely no idea what happened. And I think they're kind of setting him
up to get an Olly type arc. Like he is like the Olly of Stannis's camp right now. Jon
went to get the wildlings--a decision that seemed awful at the time but long term was
supposed to pay off. Stannis is trying to do the same thing like he's rolling the dice
little bit. He sacrificed his daughter--awful
thing--hoping that the payoff long-term would
be worth it. So the Davos is going to react to Stannis in a similar way that Olly is reacting
to Jon Snow. Next question. Noah asks: so is
there no leader of the Harpy then? Hizdahr
said everything is sorted out but he didn't try to kill daenerys. Well you know, just because
he didn't try to stab her with a knife, doesn't mean that he is not associated with the Harpies.
And i know everyone's wondering, "is he dead? is he not dead?" We did see him get stabbed
by the Harpy slot go down. We didn't see his body after he fell. If you remember back when
Grey Worm and Barristan Selmy got attacked, think about how much Grey Worm got stabbed--he's
still alive. So until we see Daenerys standing over Hizdahr's body or them remarking on Hizdahr
being dead, I think we have to assume that he is still alive. I'm totally expecting the finale to
answer that question definitively though. It feels like what they're suggesting with Daenerys'
arc is that she is going to suppress
the noble houses of Meereen. In order to do
that she's going to have to go to like Mad King territory though. Next question. James
asks: do you see Daenerys' connection with Drogon
developing further and do you think she's
going to release the two remaining dragons
and use them against the Sons of the Harpy?
I definitely think that they're going to explore her connection with the dragons more. As for
releasing the dragons, I feel like they're teasing that but it remains to be seen if
she shows up in the finale at all. Actually, I should say, yeah she is definitely going to be in
the finale. There's no way they'd leave her out. She put the dragons in chains to appease
the people but based on what happened in the
pit of the the time for that is over. It will
be a small change in the book so if that doesn't end up happening the finale, I'll explain what's different
about the books. Coz it involves like a character that they cut off the show. But definitely
plan to see more dragon fire. Next question. Samy asks: how much time has passed in the story
since the first season? So you're asking like you know, the beginning of season one what's the
timeline. Usually, I mean, approximately a year
per season but they kind of blur the
lines in the last two seasons. Next question. Dakusain asks: Lady Stoneheart? You're saying,
you know like on the show, not on the show. Strictly speaking, as it happens in the books,
No Lady Stoneheart. But it is possible they could be doing a version of her with another
character. Of all the candidates of all the people they could turn into a Lady Stoneheart-type
character, I think it would be Sansa. They've made her look more and more like her mother
every year. Magically speaking, it would have to happen as a consequence of Stannis' sacrifice.
Like an unintended consequence. All
just speculation and theories though. I'm not
expecting Lady Stoneheart but I will be
really happy if they do go that direction.
Next question. Hattie asks: why did the Sons of the Harpy look like they were attacking
the slave families in the stands if the sons are supposed to be working for said families?
You're asking like, why did it look like
the Harpies were indiscriminately just stabbing
the hell out of people. I think that they're just trying to cause chaos. They wanted Daenerys
to feel completely helpless and kill any supporters
that she might have been at arena. It be like
if half of the Night's Watch brothers that hate Jon Snow murdered the other half that
liked him. Next question. Zkerwel asks: I think I'm pronouncing that name right. What kind of power will Melisandre
and Stannis gain with the sacrifice of Shireen? Probably some intangible benefits and
some practical effects. Hopefully big twist too--something that they did not ask for.
Intangibly i think what Melisandre is hoping to do is affect the probability of the battle.
Make it so that everything that needs to happen ends up happening so that Stannis can win.
Unexpected benefits though, this is actually the big
one--what I'm hoping is, is a couple characters
die and are resurrected because of the sacrifice.
Melisandre's been really vague on what exactly
he's going to get with that sacrifice. Usually what happens is, is she sees visions in flames
so she wanted to perform the sacrifice to
bring about a more favorable outcome. The thing
about that though is, is that Melisandre has
been known to misinterpret her visions. In
the book she says that Arya will come to the wall but it ends up being the fake Arya,
Jeyne Poole. So it's this thing whereby you get what you asked for but not what you thought
you asked for. Next question. Zacarias asks: how is one dragon worth 8000 unsullied? So you're
saying you know like, how did he defeat the Sons
of the Harpy so easily? There is something
that they haven't really explained in the
show but it's called dragon fear. Way back
during Aegon's conquests, when they had the
three dragons including you know, Balerion, the Black
Dread. Well, what happened is, he would send
the dragons to burn the field between
both armies and the opposing army would all
just crap their pants and give up. They're just
so terrified by the sight of a dragon that
they couldn't even fight. So I think they wanted
to imply the little bit of that was happening
in Daznak's pit. Next question, Cthulhu asks: so Doran
mentions "four favorite nieces." Do you feel
like we'll see Sarella Sand next season? Well,
it's possible that that was just an easter egg
for the books or it was a mistake by the actors
part that they just let slide. I think that it was
intentional. They're pretty careful about
the way the edit episodes. It's possible that
there are just a couple daughters like really
young daughters that we haven't seen. They made a lot of changes to Ellaria Sand from
the books. In the books, she is the mother of
Oberyn Martell's four youngest daughters.
None of them are on the show right now. There's
Elia, Obella, Dorea and Loreza. In the
context of the show, I think what they're doing
is, is they're giving her those for youngest
ones from the books that they just they haven't
cast on the show and Tyene Sand. So technically
she has five daughters. I'm not expecting to
see them on the show next year because they
already have the Sand Snakes now and they're
probably just going to roll harder on them.
What they might do is if, if they were intending
to do Sarella's plot from the books in season
six, they'll give it to a different Sand Snake like Nymeria. As for with the other four daughters are,
I'm guessing they're playing off somewhere
in the water gardens and we'll never see
them. Next question. Elly asks: is there any
significance that Jon Snow has Jorah Mormont's
family's ancestral Valyrian blade, Long Claw?
So what you're asking is like, is anything
gonna happen with Jorah at the wall with Long
Claw because it's his Valyrian blade and
those are really important in fighting white walkers? It seems like but you know, based on the
amount of time it takes greyscale to set in,
he could make it to the time when Daenerys
is fighting white walkers. Which I think you
know eventually will come whether or
not season six of season seven but for all
intents and purposes, I think that Jorah gave
up that blade for good when he left. And it's
actually Jorah's younger sister, i think, that
is in control of Bear Island right now. She
is the one that sent the blade up to the wall
to Jeor Mormont when he was still alive. And
I think that the old bear is so ashamed
by what his son did, that he gave it to Jon
and and felt like he was giving it a good
home. So I think it will stay with Jon Snow.
Either talking about Jorah seeing the sword
at the wall in triggering some sort of redemptive
arc in him, I actually i think that's what happened
in this episode for him. This was his redemption.
But yeah, I don't think they're gonna make any
any dramatic changes to Jon Snow's weaponry.
Other than he might start carrying around a dragonglass
dagger just as backup. Thank you so much
everyone for submitting questions. These are always a
ton of fun to do. What's going to happen this
week is I'm gonna do a few extra bonus videos
just because we're heading into the finale. And then
I'll settle into like my summer Game of
Thrones bonus video schedule. So just stay tuned
for updates on that, and i will still continue
to do that the weekly Game of Thrones giveaway
whenever I post bonus videos. And don't forget
we have Comic Con coming up, too. Congratulations
to this week's giveaway winner, Chris! You win an
HBO Now subscription. Just be sure to message
me or DM me on the back end of my channel. If
you're not sure where to do that, it's on the
About page. I still have one signed copy of
A Feast for Crows. So what I'm probably going to do is
use that for my finale giveaway. Because a lot of you
asked for an Azor Ahai Night's King video,
I'm going to post that in a couple days. I'm not
going to wait till Sunday to post that. So while you guys wait for all that stuff to post, you can click
here to learn all about Asshai--the place
that Melisandre comes from. She's a shadow binder.
And you can click here for my episode nine
video. Thank you so much watching, everybody.
Let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight!